[Music]
in slowdown news you clown what I want
soda I'm just drinking drink a little
bit slow down you're gonna have to know
I submitted by know your mafia no I'm
not I'm itchy but I knew it your mafia I
knew it you were mafia the whole time
oh no is this about my diet coke a man
confronts his energy drink addiction
close your energy drink addicted what's
next because he hasn't acknowledged it
yet exactly Annie still claims to drink
a lot of water I asked him how where's
your water bringer I'm working on would
you drink so far that's a lot compared
to what it did for the day
no no one o'clock
all's not won yet it's 12:45 and he's
drinking water it's 104 yes one more I
will not do as you say I am NOT a monkey
wake up I drink this whole bottle and a
cup for the emergency even I want to
look like you and then never look like
me true that girl damn that was like as
a view line I mean it was like a dnews
line alright so this man you know what I
need to tell you this please why
actually save this article for when you
bow just for you how much you and cares
about you intervention time let me bring
out my story about Steve down you can
smoke all the crack that you want
I first met you you did not drink this
much Melissa did well I did not know
about it
why did I'm very hurt and especially
after paying many Hospital pillage
extracting your kid nothing to do with
it especially please just let me talk
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out of here I'm gonna
go get more monsters you probably don't
dream
monstercat I will have to take the cats
in whatever take of I don't give a [ __ ]
thank you it's probably a lot of salty
foods that you eat too dude it has
nothing to do with it I talk to [ __ ]
I talk to for MDS regardless or md's
they all said it has nothing if it to
have to do with your kidney stones it's
still terrible that you don't drink
water good for you let me tell you this
proof you're very dehydrated you're
dehydrated no I'm not
yesterday I went to the doctor for the
first time my life like as a physical
without being sick
and they measured my oxygen level which
is 90% and also he looked the back of my
throat and he goes wow you drink a lot
of water and I wanted to say what I
won't say it and I was like how would
you know and he was like we can tell
like most people there's that's their
throat they have this strip that's dry
and you don't have it and that's very
that's very good he's like keep it up
did you bragging well I'm saying you
should be like my oxygen that was pretty
good trying to influence you know I did
my in kidney stone they measured your
oxygen yes yes he did how do you measure
oxygen with I don't know they don't tell
you cuz he got it done yes so he told me
that it was 85 which is tight cuz that
was that was that was one of my favorite
Colts players number oh and I also told
Steve I was like you should get your
blood tests done so you can see if
you're deficient in vitamins a I already
got my blood tested and I was like well
what they say there were you deficient
he's like I don't know they didn't even
tell me anything I'm like well what did
you get it tested for and he was like
they didn't want my kidney stones like
so they didn't test for vitamin
deficiency you're delaying the article
that's driving just crazy George I just
just going bonkers back there yes yes
sorry just
let's continue this article go ahead to
continue Nikki I'm hearing all this [ __ ]
okay well Jax is like pulling wires out
over there man she's going crazy in
their house once she lives in the camera
she called wires I forget the feedback
excuse me that I want you to live longer
I'm sorry about that sorry that I want
my husband to live a long time I'm sorry
all right so you're such a good wife
this story is about Steven green his
name is Vinny he's 21
oh god he sounds like a Vinny move
[ __ ] vignette video with an Italian
accent go Vinny Vinny hey mate drink
some water mate what is an le you a
basketball term so they give you a good
shot for you to dunk it is sup cute
anyway so he got hooked on monster
energy and so good one goodness which
one does it the white one he didn't say
oh no no you did green monster
allowances yeah Steve greens monster a
drink is what it says exactly yeah so he
was doubting them during breakfast lunch
and dinner oh wow drinking six cans
every day I've never done that
[ __ ] no I do too man I do minimum twelve
minimum if I if I improve as I'm
performing or if we're writing I I have
to get some more juice for sure but
never six much in one day I'm not trying
to take this comparable to your [ __ ]
coffin that's not okay first of all I
have a one cup of coffee a day but
second of all a second how many
carcinogens are in those trophies
yeah Allah Allah okay anyway I'm not
trying to hide actually yeah I'm trying
to trying to make you drink water with
your frickin vice violation
balance it yeah coffee my morning coffee
is a weight loss
Coffee an entire water bottle because
16-ounce 16-ounce here n IG 24 out in
the morning
good job Jess she put me on this she's
like thanks she just water like a camel
off the J load up a lot of water yeah
but then they don't drink for a long
because the water is on their back there
huh okay well it's not really the best
part
not for this kid at least so he so
despite brushing his teeth twice a day
oh yeah she started getting tooth pain
and eventually when he'd been into an
apple for the front four teeth snap dude
look at your brother
this literally happened to his brother
that also drinks tons of energy drinks
he was eating tortilla chips and all and
his molar cracked and it wasn't just the
fillings not just a [ __ ] monster and
yeah well y know breaking six cans of
the sugar one a day no [ __ ] literally
just said the story yesterday tortilla
and [ __ ] dude my teeth are stronger than
your teeth like that well that's what
this is I'll bite something alright love
you guys bye bye rusty I can trust him
you can't bite me I bet they have that
for like canines we don't want to take
them off the platform ordering on Amazon
I want just do another video whose teeth
are stronger you're not the same you
wouldn't know cuz he never goes to the
dentist making yourself sound bad though
cuz you volunteered to be his wife
that's true you're not gross you just
don't take care of your health
that's all that's gross preventive care
so Vinny here he was drinking 45 cans a
week for seven months and then uh he
discovered when you so he was hiding his
teeth from his mom because he was really
embarrassed so he talked to her like
this
he's 21 like a turtle it's so adorable
lot years of loneliness so much
enthusiasm to it that's what I love
about it don't sounds like he's talking
yeah the whole purpose of this whole
article okay oh my god [ __ ] insane
sick kids awake for seven months would
imagine the damage that you're doing
throughout the month very foundation
he's I know but he's wearing foundation
not I did oh my god oh my god I brush my
teeth like a [ __ ] and I thank
you well that ain't happened to me I've
been doing monsters for ten years bro
you trying to test the universe here I
don't brush my teeth that much and it
doesn't even look like that that is
gross 24 Oz boy needs dentures for his
something out like he's like he did meth
or something too
any suck a lot of dick yeah what the
[ __ ] is hey
with me girl you hear that and just hear
that what do you think suck it dick is
bad I think we have toxic juices coming
out of our game
don't say the [ __ ] I shouldn't stop
doing that I mean no coming inside the
dog that only affects men only oh yeah
yeah so gay mixer of life the truth
the loominatee is out what about gay
guys it's okay cuz they want to do oh
but if you're not gay and you don't want
the dick but you're still sucking on it
then it it's like it understands that
it's not supposed to sucking a dick you
don't want yeah yeah didn't know about
rape victims yeah yep what about them
yeah it does it's a defense mechanism
[ __ ] switches in there right now guys
she's [ __ ] hitting red buttons and
[ __ ] video she's called command
center dude she's like buckets calling
down save the company Jets
yeah I'll blame her one bit I didn't say
nothing justice freckles are falling off
and she's put them back
she works hard a few things safer I want
to see sweaty buckles
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]